want to spoil your girlfriend with
diamonds while impressing her with your
scientific knowledge here's how baby
we've been together a long time and I've
picked up on your hints I know that you
want a diamond but I was thinking you're
too special to me for just one diamond I
want to give you one and a half million
diamonds per second and not only that
they're nano diamonds really yeah isn't
that great nano diamonds you are a so
now is the perfect time to tell her that
scientists have recently discovered nano
diamonds in the flames of ordinary
candles millions of them as the
hydrocarbon wax is burned diamonds form
in the middle of the flame what did the
exact same as regular diamond just
really really small you always told me
size doesn't matter are you packing I
should put this into my thumb actually
as it turns out the Nano diamonds are
burnt up in the flame and released into
the atmosphere as carbon dioxide so
you're probably better off getting a big
diamond otherwise your relationship like
the nano diamonds will go up in smoke
you